the jogan experience and I hear the
helicopter coming coming in but it
sounds like it's freaking below me and
I've just got me sleeping uh not me
sleeping bag out me um mattress cuz it's
bright orange to flag them down in like
the
clouds so I walk onto the far side of
the tent and I can just every now and
then see these lights flashing and
they're like a 100 yards below me flying
in the clouds and I hear this Chopper
like coming in I'm like it's going to
it's I thought it was going to smash
straight into the mountain and you see
them coming in coming in like I mean
it's like sheer Rock straight below me
and the helicopters below me and then
they seen that they were about to fly
into the rock wall and then they pulled
back and then I just heard them leave
and I'm like [__] I'm here now for the
next four or 5 days what sucked was in
the Panic of them saying yeah we're
coming to pick you up now I packed up
and got super wet like packing up in the
snow was starting to drizzle out of them
clouds so I was already wet my sleeving
bag was wet everything was wet from
packing up I'm like [__] this I probably
should start hiking out and then so I
looked at my
GPS and it looked at the time like it
was a pretty gradual climb all the way
down into this Creek like so there's a
glacier up above me and it's been
melting for however many years and it's
carved out like a bit of a creek and so
it looks safe and then I started
climbing down and it the first I don't
know 2 hours wasn't too bad like it was
pretty gradual bit of rock hopping and
slippery stuff and I had one little leap
to do it was
like 2 and 1/2 M or a meter down on onto
a rock to go out to this next Rock and
it was like there was a big Glacier pool
below me and it sounds weird but you're
calculating everything as you're going
you know so it's like this is the best
place to jump down because if I did fall
at least I'm landing in water and and
that's just a two second process in your
head you know and that that's happening
all day like they there's never a point
that you can switch off in that country
like you're constantly on the ball
otherwise that's when you're going to
come un
star anyway what I didn't realize was
the rock that I was jumping down onto
had actually quite a bit of a slope to
it and it had like clear ice a layer of
clear ice on it you got to remember I
got this shammy in my backpack and
freaking a wet wet everything cuz I
packed up in the wet so the pack weighs
a lot and it weighs a lot anyway cuz
you're going back for like 14 days man I
hit this Rock and my feet come out from
under me that fast that like it was just
like full chest weight on the Rock bang
started sliding off the rock backwards
so I'm on my stomach sliding backwards
legs going first and I slide off the
back of that rock and I got a heavy
backpack on so it just pulled me I just
started pluming down to this ice cold
water and like back neck first straight
into the water and I just remember
hitting the water it pulled me all the
way under like like it was a good enough
fall probably 6 7even M down in into it
from the where the rock slid off and it
pulled me under I just remember my
breath getting sucked out of me like
like I mean like it's Crystal Clear like
that blue water straight off a glacia
and it ripped me down and then sort of I
struggled to come back up get to the
surface and by the time I got to the
surface CU it was flowing pretty hard it
was pushing me into one of the drainage
shoots from it and then so I hit this
drainage shoot sort of scrambling trying
to grab on and then it pulled me down
legs first as well like down into the
Chute in the next lot of water then by
the time I got to that point there was
no like there was no going back up there
was no chance I could go back up because
it's dropped me into a spot where I
wasn't on the sides of the bank anymore
I was stuck in this glacia um melt and
then I end up getting out of there and I
got to the next point there was like a
big tree like falling down in the water
there's no trees on the side it's just
whatever's been washed down over the
years like a big stump and I end up
wrapping my hand around that my arm
around that get to my legs and then like
weigh twice as much again cuz now
everything's you know full of water and
soaked you still have the Pack on yeah I
still got the pack on and then and then
I got like got up on the Rock then it's
just like one rock in all this water and
then it's a [__] long story so I'll
probably skip a few
bits but I end up like fighting with it
for the rest of the day and then I end
up falling over another two times one
time I actually had to volunteer to jump
I had nowhere to go I was just like
stuck in this little canyon in the water
and I literally had to come up with the
guts to be like jump into the next water
shoot which is just like a slide cut out
of the rocks from the water running down
there for [__] millions of years and
I've still got my backpack on I can't
leave nothing cuz that could be what
saves me at the end of the day I got to
sleeping bag I got other clothes in
there I got um meat from the chamy I I
had the skin from the shammy I still had
everything in there and um I like have
you ever done anything where you [__]
like propably got to convince yourself
to do it because like I was I didn't
know if that was going to kill me going
to the next step or if that was going to
save my life and then so you're
calculating all that and then having to
have the gut to actually jump into the
next shoot of water and go down man I
[__] I just remember just [__]
doing it and I jumped perfect I landed
on the backpack I put all the weight on
the backpack slid into the next bit just
like pump with adrenaline right so I'm
not even feeling the cold at this point
cuz adrenaline's just going
sick and I end up going down a bit
further and then I could just hear this
like deafening sound of water and I'm
like [__] me dead like what next cuz
constantly it seemed to be like what
next what next what's next and I hear
this deafening sound of water and I get
to the [__] Edge and it's like free
400 yard straight down straight down oh
my God and it's just like like then it
was like no there's no going any further
you're like to go further is definitely
deaf you need to work something out here
you know and it got to the point it
takes a lot of courage to even be like I
need someone to save me like at least
for me because I've like I've always you
know like it's it's the way that you're
brought up the the way that I was
brought up cuz you know i' never had the
Father Figure in my life I didn't have
any of that so it was always everything
I do I do for myself that's why I never
usually ask people for help this is the
biggest ask for help there [__] is
right and it's pressing the SOS button
on the emergency device you know and
it's like and I sat there for 20 minutes
and still pumped with adrenaline over
that time I [__] like getting adrenaline
talking about it
now and then realizing there's [__]
definitely no way off here it's time to
hit the button like this is where you
don't get to see your family again or
you don't get to do any of this again or
live life you need to hit hit the button
and just [__] like still hitting the
button hurt and you got to hold it in
for like 10 or 20 seconds it was [__]
the longest 10 seconds of my life and
like at this point I've taken the
backpack off I took a jacket off because
it was just so [__] heavy and wet and
it's sitting there and I'm holding the
button in for like 10 seconds and it's
like then it's like SOS you know and
it's like a
[__] and then but there's no reply to it
or anything like that at that point it's
it sort of just says the signal
successful as incent and that's about it
and it's getting late and I'm like I
need to set up some sort of Camp I need
to go for my pack see what I can use
like what's going to work out here and I
pull my pack out and then like I've only
got a spot that's like the size of one
body laying down to even stand on in
this area and it's barely flat the only
thing that's kept it flat is a trees
falling off from up at the Alpine tops
at some point in its life falling down
there and then all the Shale and rock
that's fallen off these big wash outs
with the water has like leaned up
against that big stump so it's like laid
out a flat bit and I could fit about 3/4
of a little oneperson tent on there and
so I set the tent up there I set the um
mattress that I was telling you that I
was trying to flag down the helicopter
where if I'd set that just on there that
just sat on there and I pulled the
sleeping bag out and it was [__]
soaked like the sleeping bag was
drenched and I'm like it's still going
to be
something and went for the rest of me
pack I pulled the shammy skin out and
sort of laid that there hoping it' give
me some warmth as well and i' i' like
stripped down then um all the like
bigger layers to try and get that off me
and I climbed in this wet cold sleeping
bag which is the worst feeling [__]
ever in that situation like you do you
start you're starting to think like this
is this is the end this might be de and
I climbed in there I was trying to get
warm and then I kept looking at that
signal but my phone like it's through my
phone uh my phone it's usually through
my phone sorry my phone had already died
so it's just through the little device
and remember the old phones how you had
to go for the [__] alphabet on them
to type a message I I'm trying to type a
message to my buddy that was keeping
tabs on me as all this was happening and
and the message just went out as in I
need help and he like like I've been
around this dude for forever he's one of
my best friends so he knows what I'm
like he he knows if I'm like I [__]
need help that it's not good you know
and that message I didn't know if it
went out or not I had to turn it off
because I had like four 5% in it so I
shut it
down anyway I'm laying in there laying
in there and then obviously the
adrenaline's calming off and I think I
dozed off for a little while it might
have been 40 minutes or so like a power
nap and I woke up and my body was just
quivering flat out like like from
[__] deep in it was just quivering
flat out and that feels like death that
probably that that actually it scared me
cuz like I couldn't stop I was just
[__] quivering flat out like hyp like
my core is trying to warm back up yeah
and it took me to took me a little while
to think about that cuz I I shut I end
up shutting myself down I stopped myself
shaking and then I was like you [__]
idiot that's exactly what your body's
supposed to do I was trying to warm up
and then I sort of loosened up again and
it started shaking and then I went to
move this arm and this leg and they
wouldn't move like I couldn't move them
and then I was like ah [__] like as in
the adrenaline it was from that first
fall I think or it was from the jump
that I
did um I don't know if i' bruised it I
don't know if it's about nearly
hypothermic I don't know what really
happened there just I just couldn't move
that leg and I couldn't move this arm so
then that scared me a bit too and I
started thinking about Kim and the kids
and like like shook me up and then and I
got te as well which was weird cuz then
I [__] warmed up like when all that
happened I was starting to warm up
anyway I tried to sleep you can't sleep
you're in a wet sleeping bag it's free
like everything's [__] Frozen around
you there's [__] rocks rolling from
the top of the [__] Mountain down
into the river that what the creek
that's now turned into a river there's
rocks rolling down there you're
listening to that all night there's like
smaller debris and rocks hitting the
tent it's just like and you can't move
cuz I'm on a pad this
big anyway I don't even know how but the
morning came at some point I got up
turned the GPS back on no there was no
message no nothing so I hit the SOS one
last time and I held it in nothing
nothing I think I sat around for the
first couple of hours of morning like
just holding me chest and stuff like
that trying to get warm again and I got
to the point and it's like no one's
coming for you like it's [__] on you
and that was the best thing that
happened to me because it was almost
like I hit the button and it was almost
like a give up as in like oh someone's
coming for me it's fine you know and
then it wasn't till I realized and said
to myself no one's [__] coming just
[__] get up and do something and I
was like I'm [__] going to start a
fire even if it takes me half a day at
least this is turning let's try and
start a fire let's do something you know
like [__] stay in it and then so I
started pulling all the different
rubbish out of me bag that I carried
from the trip started piling that up
there's like no branches or anything
around so then I'm back at that tree
where my tent was and I'm trying to
carve into that tree like to try and get
into the middle of it try and find some
dryer cuz you know it's been raining for
you know a day and a half now maybe even
longer down low cuz I descended so far
down and then I'm trying to get in there
and I'm like I'll burn the tent I'll
burn what else can I burn you know I
started thinking about all the things
that I can burn I'm like yeah if you're
here for another night you can't that
you can't burn any of that right so I
left the tent set up left the shammy
skin in there and then I just got it to
the point where I was like I could
probably start a fire now it's not going
to last long cuz there's no wood on it
it's just all you know trash that I had
in my
bag and then I started thinking what
else can I do I'm like you know I'm
going to build a [__] helicopter pad
cuz there was no you know it was all
Shear like no commercial helicopter
could live there uh land there only a
rescue helicopter at that point could
pick me up from where I was because they
you know they could drop down a rope and
lift me up but if I build an actual pad
I knew once the weather cleared I could
just call in the commercial helicopter
to pick me up so I was like [__] it and
I'm so I start grabbing like rocks there
just rocks everywhere and I was going to
build basically a retaining wall and
then start filling it it would have
taken days to do but I was just Keen to
keep busy and then I was fully trapped I
could not go back up I couldn't go out
the creek I couldn't go out the sides I
definitely couldn't go down low and that
Roars the whole time right beside me
just screaming that water pumping down
there anyway so I start collecting rocks
and then I thought I heard a [__]
helicopter and I was like [__] and this
is like this is 5 or 6 hours now after
morning and I'm listening and it's
getting louder I just see this [__]
big helicopter Bank up this like it's a
[__] you're in a drawer system in
between these massive mountains and it
just comes cruising straight around and
I was like holy [__] like I was like so
[__] pumped and then this arm still
wasn't working I got this leg to Mo
start working in the morning this arm
still wasn't working properly and I was
so [__] pumped and the dude comes
around and he gives me the thumbs up oh
[__] man my fum must have been so
straight I was [__] like this you know I
was so
excited